you're a very good musician by the piano
very well and what I didn't know is that
when you were a kid playing the piano
you had a dream to be in a boy band is
that right
yes jazz piano is my safety and I wanted
to be the frontman of a boy band so what
was your favorite boy band when you were
a kid new kids on the block so I that
but that's the one part you guys should
have not supported they were a big deal
back in the day they were they were and
they were awesome and they and they all
had rat tails and so I did the first
thing that a man or a boy does when he
wants to become a musician which is grow
a rat tail and have my mother braid it
at night and and I learned the moves and
I sang and my parents looked at me with
the look the look of oh you you you
shouldn't you shouldn't pursue this it's
very similar to the look of like good
job yes keep following your dreams so I
cuz they said you're yes but I know
inside it was deaf it was it was the end
of the road for me so they said we
should take piano lessons just got me
you're a great singer but just to help
and and then I I did and I took a lot I
played jazz and I never got into opera
because I wasn't cool enough for the
opera scene you're definitely the
coolest one here well yeah I want to
talk to make sure that we show a clip
from this film it's a based on a true
events yes story about this woman with
incredible played by Meryl Streep who
has incredible resources and her dream
is to sing and of course that is not her
strong suit no and she's so brilliant
she's always brilliant but to
intentionally sing well I mean to
intentially sing badly is extremely
difficult yeah someone who as Mel's feet
can sing so well yeah she's she's
brilliantly atrocious in this as playing
the singer everyone knows that she's the
worst singer of the world has ever known
except for her right because she's rich
no one will tell her yeah and it's her
dream and it's you know people are
celebrating her her passion despite her
her complete talent free nature
you